we're asked to plot the image of
quadrilateral abcd so that's this blue
quadrilateral here under a reflection
across the x-axis so that's the x-axis
and we have our little tool here on khan
academy where we can construct a
quadrilateral and we need to construct
the reflection of triangle a b
c d
and so what we can do is let me scroll
down a little bit so we can see the
entire coordinate axis we want to find
the reflection across the x-axis so i'm
going to reflect point by point actually
let me just move this whole thing
down here so that we can
so we can see what is going on a little
bit clearer
so let's just first
reflect point let me move this a little
bit out of the way
so let's first reflect reflect point a
so we're going to reflect across the
x-axis a is four units above the x-axis
one two three four
so it's image a prime we could say would
be four units below the x-axis so one
two three four so let's make this right
over here a
a prime i'm having trouble putting the
see if i move these other characters
around okay there you go so this is
going to be my a prime now let me try b
b is 2 units above the x axis so b prime
is going to have the same x coordinate
but it's going to be 2 units below the x
axis so let's make this our b so this is
our b right over here now let's make
this rc
c right here has the x coordinate of
negative 5 and a y coordinate of
negative 4.
now c prime would have the same x
coordinate but instead of being four
units below the x-axis it'll be four
units above the x-axis so it would have
the coordinates negative five comma
positive four so this is going to be our
c here so this goes to negative five one
two three positive 4.
and then last but not least d
and so let's see d right now is at
negative 2 comma negative 1. if we
reflect across the x-axis instead of
being 1 unit below the x-axis we'll be
one unit above the x-axis and we'll keep
our x-coordinate of negative two and so
there you have it we have constructed
the reflection of a b c d across the
x-axis and what's interesting about this
example is that the original
quadrilateral
is on top of the x-axis so you can kind
of see this top part of the
quadrilateral gets reflected below it
and this bottom part of the
quadrilateral gets reflected above it
and then you can see that indeed do they
they indeed do look like reflections
flipped over the x-axis